[Musique]
à
la dernière séance d'aujourd'hui est
consacrée à un élu écologiste qui a
beaucoup fait parler de lui pendant
cette législature matthieu orphelin élu
sous les couleurs dans marche dans le
maine et loire il a fini par rompre avec
la majorité et cinq ans plus tard il a
donc décidé de ne pas se représenter
bonjour mathieu orphelin bonjour alors
en cinq ans vous avez siéger dans trois
groupes politiques différents avant de
devenir un député non-inscrit ça n'a pas
été un long fleuve tranquille pour vous
ce mandat c'est clair ça a été 50
combats 50 d'inattendu l'inde épisodes
qu'on n'aurait pas pu imaginer en 2017
mais voilà mandat cinq ans qui sont
passés en quelques secondes et qui vous
a donné quelques cheveux gris quand on
voit les photos de
l'impression d'avoir pris dix ans cinq
ans alors vous faites le bilan de ces
cinq ans dans un livre qui vient de
sortir en librairie aux éditions rue de
l'échiquier à caen l'écologie en grand
en sous titre ce qu'il reste à faire et
le bilan est bon on va le faire ensemble
dans cette dernière séance si vous le
voulez bien vous êtes prêt prêt et là
c'est parti
alors mature phelim dans le film de ces
cinq années à l'assemblée on a
l'impression que tout se joue presque
dans la première scène l'une des toutes
premières réunions du groupe en marche à
l'assemblée à l'époque c'est richard
ferrand qui présidait ce groupe et entre
vous de ce jour là ça s'est pas très
bien passé non dès la première réunion
de groupe avec richard ferrand on a eu
un affrontement parce que on devait
acter le règlement du groupe lrm et il y
avait un passage qui me posait problème
il était dit qu'il fallait toujours voté
comme le décideur le groupe sa s'est
évidemment pas possiblement d'impératifs
ça n'existe pas donc je prends c'est
vraiment des impératifs c'est la
discipline de vote mais plus loin parce
que et on vous savez roselyne bachelot
qui a été député cinq ans sur la
circonscription où je suis élue m'avait
dit votre toujours avec tes convictions
jamais avec des consignes de groupe ça
t'évitera de faire bien des conneries et
j'avais prévenu richard la veille on lui
dire voilà je demanderai une petite
modification
sur ce point là et en fait j'ai exposé
je suis le premier à parler à la réunion
de groupe et là richard ferrand plutôt
que d'être conciliant me rentrer dedans
je crois qu'il voulait remettre de
l'ordre il était encore traumatisé par
l'expérience des frondeurs même façon
sans discipline de vote il ya plus de
majorité c'est un peu le b à ba de la
politique sous la soul à 5 chaque fois
et dès ce jour là à chaque fois ils ont
fait un esclandre et un problème de
l'abstention et du vote compte de
quelques députés 3 que ça nuit à
l'efficacité du groupe de la majorité
j'en suis parti assez rapidement et je
crois que ça a nui aussi à la place du
parlement dans notre vie politique alors
cette réunion de groupe c'est un peu la
scène d'ouverture on va dire la scène
d'affrontement elle a eu lieu moins d'un
an plus tard sur un désengagement des
manuels macron pendant sa campagne qui
était d'interdire le glyphosate dans les
trois ans qui suivait son élection on va
revoir un extrait de votre intervention
ce jour là ou plutôt cette nuit là cet
amendement propose de traduire dans la
loi l'engagement pris par le président
de la république de réussir la sortie du
glyphosate en trois ans sans laisser
aucun agriculteur sans solution et
l'amendement est rédigée de façon à
prévoir toutes les exceptions toutes les
exemptions et d'accompagner tous les
agriculteurs alors le vote sur votre
amendement il a eu lieu en pleine nuit
ça a été un échec pour vous il n'ya pas
et il n'a pas été adopté est ce que
finalement la vraie rupture politique
pour vous avec cette majorité elle ne
remonte pas à ce jour là si ces nuits
effectivement rien ne se passe comme
prévu une heure du matin richard ferrand
et ses députés proches reviennent dans
l'hémicycle à richard me dit d'ailleurs
s'assoit devant moi et me dit bah de
balorre tu n'es pas content de voir ton
président en gros on joue effectivement
là sur ces images un soir il vous
regarde pendant que vous pendant que
vous parlez voilà il décide mais c'était
sa place dans l'hémicycle c'est mauvais
ça cela s'installe là et plutôt que de
me faire battre gentiment il décide avec
le ministre de l'agriculture de l'époque
de me faire une leçon de lire c'est
n'importe quoi alors que je faisais
juste que traduire dans la loi un
engagement du président de la république
d'ailleurs le lendemain jeudi à mannheim
macron je vais partir dans les
prochaines semaines ça peut pas durer
comme ça j'essaie de traduire un des
engagements je me fait bâcher part la
majorité et le président de l'uimm est
inquiète ça va changer d'ailleurs les
ministres le lendemain monte au front
pendant les émissions dire on fera une
loi dans 18 mois et voilà mais
effectivement où il ya une première
rupture je le dis pas publiquement ce
jour là mais effectivement là je perds
confiance en eux la rupture officielle
avec la république en marche elle s'est
faite le 6 février 2019 dans un courrier
vous adresser à vos anciens collègues et
les rues même quand vous quittez le
groupe vous parler d'un échec collectif
mais est-ce que c'est pas plutôt l'échec
de votre stratégie à vous qui était de
changer les choses de l'intérieur et
quand on part sur cette stratégie là on
doit accepter d'avoir plus de défaites
que de victoires quant au
bout d'un an et demi de mandat je prends
cette décision qui était très difficile
à l'époque de quitter la majorité je
t'aime des premiers à quitter la
majorité je le fais parce que sur aucun
des grands chantiers la rénovation
énergétique les mobilités l'agriculture
la finance verte on n'est pas au bon
rythme et donc moi j'ai en tête ce que
disent les scientifiques sur la baisse
des émissions qu'il faut faire et la
réalité d'une majorité qui préfère se
dire on fait plus que ceux d'avant la
belle affaire heureusement tu m'as qu'on
fait plus collant des copains ne faisait
plus que sarkozy mais la vraie question
c'est est ce qu'on est à la hauteur des
enjeux de ce que nous disent les
scientifiques
alors votre modèle a aussi été marquée
par un joli coup médiatique c'était au
mois de juillet 2019 petit rappel en
images waouh
qu'est-ce qu'on est content que vous
soyez là merci beaucoup surtout ne
lâchez rien
continuez à vous mobiliser face à
l'avalanche de compliments crête
attenberg fait l'amour pas franchement
convaincu j'ai l'impression que vous
n'avez pas bien compris ce que nous
disons
plutôt que de nous féliciter pour ce que
nous faisons essayer de faire quelque
chose c'est vous qui avait fait venir
greta thunder ya à l'assemblée quand on
voit cet extrait les députés
applaudissent alors qu'elle leur fait
clairement la leçon on a le sentiment
d'un immense décalage entre elles et les
députés ou décalage entre la jeunesse
les scientifiques et puis les députés
qui mélangeait sa formidable que la
jeunesse soit là mais pour bébés qui
n'ont pas compris ce qu elle leur disait
ils ont pas compris mais je vais vous
demander au delà du coup médiatique
c'est a servi à quoi concrètement ça
sert vise à changer quelque chose dans
la vision des choses que parent
déshérités passé et moi je je le dis
dans le livre je crois que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui député c'est ce que
j'appelle la pleine conscience
écologique et climatique
aujourd'hui un certain klimato
relativisme des députés qu'ils
comprennent bien que c'est un sujet
important le climat mais qui n'arrive
pas à le mettre à la hauteur des enjeux
parce que si on perd la bataille pour le
climat on perd tout ce qui a de
l'importance à nos yeux on va passer à
la séquence suivante séquence vérité en
quelque sorte en tout cas sans langue de
bois
alors il ya des sujets encore tabous en
politique et le burn out en fait partie
vous en avez été victime fin 2019 et
vous avez décidé d'en parler
publiquement récemment pourquoi c'est
une maladie voix qui vous tombe dessus
il ya quand même entre 30000 et 50000
burnout grave par an en france donc
3 millions je crois de salariés qui sont
en situation de risque le burn-out et
quand on perd les pédales à cause d'un
excès de travail en c'est travail voilà
c'est la maladie de bon élève un moment
voulaient toujours faire plus comme moi
j'essaie d'être tout le temps présent
sur tous les combats puis un moment
votre corps vous dis stop et depuis vous
avez changé votre façon de travailler
vous vous êtes fixé des limites oui bien
sûr parce que toute la question est là
c'était moi j'ai eu de la chance d'être
que ce soit vis diagnostiqué d'être
super bien suivi par mes médecins mais
on à repenser complètement les méthodes
de travail par exemple l'addiction au
téléphone j'ai plus depuis cette date
j'ai puis les réseaux sociaux ni les
mails sur mes téléphones
j'arrête de lire la presse et de
regarder toutes les chaînes d'info et
lcp toute la journée
apprendre à dire non aussi différentes
sollicitations donc arriver à mettre une
distance qui permettent je crois gagner
en plus en efficacité alors passer à un
sujet plus léger autour d'un diabolo
menthe
alors c'est comme si on y était où ça et
bien à la buvette de l'assemblée ce lieu
réservé aux députés c'est un endroit que
vous avez fréquenté pendant pendant ces
cinq années évidemment c'est un endroit
très sympathique je les ai jamais fait
d'excès je crois en moi et c'est
évidemment un endroit sympa alors
imaginez c'est votre dernier jour à
l'assemblée avec qu'est-ce que vous
prendriez un dernier verre dans cette
buvette j'inviterais sans doute ugo
bernalicis de la france a soumises parce
que on s'entend bien même si on est deux
styles complètement différents lui le
hâbleur cadors faire des déclassés puis
moi et des imitations dans les
imitations qui fait plutôt pas mal et
puis chez les rues m javi très bien
roland lescure parce que roland lescure
on est sur des options politiques
radicalement différente mais on a eu
beaucoup de débats ensemble sur amazon
sur les pesticides ou sur d'autres
thèmes et à chaque fois ça a été des
débats sans coups en dessous de la de la
ceinture mais ça c'est plutôt agréable
même si j'aimerais bien qu'ils soient un
peu plus écologiste mais il a le temps
les jeunes lice représente représente
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui va vous
manquer en quittant l'assemblée tout
tout garde à vous pour que vous la
quittez pas ce que j'ai expliqué voilà
c'était une décision difficile mais puis
je voulais pas devenir un professionnel
de la politique de plus mais tout va
manquer c'est quand même l'assemblée
nationale le lieu pour faire changer les
choses en politique on a vécu des choses
tellement dur mais tellement forte et
puis c'est voilà faire de la politique
au niveau national changer la vie des
gens ghani un amendement à une ou deux
voix près portez des causes voilà tout
ça c'est évidemment une chance moi j'ai
une chance je remercie la destinée alors
pu être là et servir les habitants et
les habitantes du maine-et-loire et plus
globalement de la france donc oui ça va
être compliqué de gérer ce manque on va
parler un peu de votre avenir à présent
le premier jour de votre vie après
l'assemblée
alors dans ce livre que vous venez de
publier vous écrivez la politique est
une drogue dure il va falloir que
j'apprivoise le manque quand on entend
tout ce que vous venez de dire
effectivement on se dit en fait vous
vous n'êtes pas prêt d'arrêter la
politique quoi peut-être que j'en ferais
peut-être que dans quelques années après
on sait pas la vie comment voilà moi je
fais arrivée en politique un peu par
hasard
vous avez l'air totalement accro en fait
quand on vous entend parler vous avez
pas tués a trop allongé la page j'ai
envie de changer des choses est de
continuer à changer des choses est ce
que m'a appris mon parcours pas très
linéaire faut l'avouer c'est que quand
vous êtes dans une ong comme je l'étais
quand vous êtes dans une
d'établissements publics sur ces sujets
là vous pouvez aussi faire bouger les
lignes au problème c'est que j'ai
beaucoup d'énergie donc il faut que
cette énergie là je l'utilisé que
j'utilise pour faire avancer les causes
écologiques et solidaires et voilà je
sais pas encore comment mais encore 20
je retrouve un travail comme beaucoup de
français ne faisaient aucune idée pour
l'instant de dire mais moi je pense
qu'il faut que je sois sur ces thèmes
qu'elle je bosse depuis 25 ans sur
lequel il a tant de choses à changer et
puis plus tôt dans une institution
publique ou une ong que dans une
entreprise même si je me ferme aucune
porte mais j'ai pas de plan de carrière
j'en ai jamais fait c'est pas 49 ballet
que je vais commencer à en faire mais ce
que je sais c'est que je suis plus fort
qu'en arrivant ici j'ai mieux armé et
puis cette expérience un peu folle que
j'ai vécu il faut que je la mette au
service d'autres façons de mener les
combats il n'y a pas que la politique
n'y a pas que la vie économique il n'y a
pas que l'engagement dans les associés
chacun à son poste et c'est bien de
changer de poste parce que ça permet de
mieux comprendre aussi les choses aller
pour conclure si vous deviez résumer
votre mandat en un titre de film est ce
que ce serait plutôt dans ce look up
grosse fatigue ou le bonheur est dans le
pré
quand même donc donc look up finalement
c'est vrai que dans ce film on reconnaît
tellement de choses qu'on a qu'on a vécu
moi je me suis enfui en face tous les
lobbys les pesticides l'industrie
pétrolière
tous et tous des fois avec des
manoeuvres tellement forte que dans ce
film ce qui est intéressant c'est à la
fois cette déconnexion de la réalité des
politiques puis c'est aussi toutes les
forces et toutes les moyens qui sont à
la disposition du du récit officiel et
donc voilà je crois que c'est un film
d'ailleurs qu'à bien marquer beaucoup
marqué les gens maintenant il faut que
de ses prises de conscience là il est
une concrétisation dans l'action dans
les luttes merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu partager donc cette dernière séance
avec nous à bientôt
[Musique]